man you you and uh rio been doing your
thing bro obviously free rio uh but you
guys have been um
just on a tear independently
for a minute just putting on for the
city um how's he doing how's his spirits
oh good see that's one thing about reed
he always i experienced no matter the
situation so it was like
he good man he you know he don't like he
wanted them personal people that don't
like to see he don't want to know
he's not going to let you know he
worried about it right you're a leader
what's uh what's like the status with
him anyway as far as like when he when
is he going to be getting out like uh
originally
you know he was he was sentenced to five
years
but you know i out of fears go
so we dinner who's looking at like what
three and a half
and maybe you can be even sooner you
never know because you know they laws
change every day they get programs and
[ __ ] like that so i'm hoping they you
know they just said that the house of
representatives like uh
passed the
idea of taking weed off of the federal
like list you know because it's
federally like still it's still in the
same category as like cocaine and
you know in michigan you they got it's
recreational now right right but
everywhere is still federally illegal so
um hopefully when that happens they're
just gonna let a ton of [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of jail yeah you would
hope so
oh so go ahead and let my baby out man
he's a superstar